cbs this morning is here in las vegas
this morning as you see there lily
luciano is live on the las vegas strip
this morning
lilia good morning to you you've got a
first-hand look at some of the efforts
by federal officials here in the valley
to try and get the vaccine to more of
the public good morning to you what did
you see
good morning john well yesterday we
spent some time
with governor siselek and with the
health and uh
health and human services secretary
javier becerra as they deployed the
first
of what's called a covet surge response
team this is a multi-agency effort
that shows up in states at the request
of the governor to deal
with case surges with access to
vaccination
specifically here in vegas as you know
vegas has the highest positivity rate in
the nation
and a low vaccination rate some of that
is people who are hesitant to get
the vaccine because of lack of
information or
confidence and also lack of access so
what they're doing is deploying these
teams
to go door to door talk to people make
them feel more comfortable with the
science with the information of the
value of the vaccine
and also uh provide access through local
uh partnerships and local groups that
are working hard to curb the spread of
of coven
it's been an ongoing effort to try and
get here in las vegas some parts of our
community more
uh comfortable with getting the vaccine
what did you see in terms of
just trying to get them comfortable how
do you convince folks that maybe are
hard to convince to get that medicine
something that they say is working well
is that partnership
with community liaisons with people who
are already part of the community who
were trusted
we met a man yesterday whose name is
jefferson
he's already working in this community
uh talking to people
providing them access to health care and
whatever information
they need and so once
he knows the people once he has that
kind of access in the community
then people kind of trust him better and
they can listen more to the science to
the information that's provided
so it's not you know just the federal
agencies showing up door knocking
but actually working within the
community and those community groups
that are already doing the outreach and
already doing the efforts
but of course with added support
resources uh
workforce we also uh coming up in our
story on cbs this morning
got to talk and got a rare inside look
here at one of the mgm properties at the
aria hotel and casino
to understand what they're doing not
just to keep their employees safe by
offering vaccine clinics and testing but
also
to protect visitors and and people who
go to their resorts in terms of
uh the technologies that they use to
clean up the air and and things like
that
yeah lily we just saw some video there
of you uh walking around some of the
resorts here on the strip as well it's
not just getting the community uh
comfortable with vaccinations it's the
taurus it's the folks on the trip as
well leela thank you very much for
joining us this morning we will see you
at 7 o'clock
later here on cbs this morning here on
channel 8. appreciate your time